hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday march 28 2022
um
yeah i'm doing this on tuesday march
29th uh got a little i didn't get busy i
did the [ __ ] podcast it's just i
don't know what's going on i just my
computer is not recognizing my interface
i don't know if i need a new cord or
what it's [ __ ] charging the thing i
have no idea but jesus louise what a day
to not have your podcast uploaded
possibly
quite possibly one of the most shocking
moments
in pop culture slash art
history
i don't you know very few things leave
me absolutely speechless but
i don't know if you guys saw the clip
from the oscars in uh 2022.
um
i didn't think i would ever see this but
a drummer
turned director
won an oscar for an incredible
documentary
called summer's soul
when the revolution could not be
televised or was yeah could not be
televised uh i don't know if you saw
quest speech it was amazing i don't know
if you saw that documentary
uh it was incredible and i just want to
say i'm so freaking happy for that guy
because if you don't follow him on um
social media or anything like that you
really got to do it like because i got
to be honest with you the amount of
musical rabbit holes
that that guy has set me down and
they've never been bad and i've always
discovered all of this muse air quote
discovered
all of this uh music that i had never
heard before
you know
genres and subsets of genres and
you know people that like almost made it
but didn't quite you know break
mainstream or something um
it's it's been an amazing amazing person
to follow on uh instagram or twitter and
he gave
an incredible speech
and what i also liked about it was nice
and quick too
um
got like right to the point so um
just so freaking happy for him that was
a great thing to see so check it out if
you haven't seen it the summer
of seoul
um
yeah i think that's it that's all i have
to say about the oscars
um other than when chris rock comes and
does a show in l.a i'm definitely not
missing that show
um all right well as always we got um
we got the um
you know this is going to be one of
these these podcast sliders
because uh you know
i gotta go do [ __ ] to go do this [ __ ]
and i'm i'm six days away from rapping
on this thing and we had one of the
biggest scenes
one of the most intricate scenes to
write and make sure i got the tone of it
correctly and
you know the actors absolutely [ __ ]
smashed it yesterday and uh
i felt like a thousand pounds was taken
off my chest and i just felt like i got
the movie i got the movie now you know
you know we still got a bunch of work to
do
you know it's like
you know you're jumping across rocks
across the river i feel like i got all
the pieces now
so
then we'll see that i go into editing
and all of that type of stuff oh [ __ ]
uh billy big steps here getting outside
his comfort zone
um
yeah other than that i don't even know
what's going on other than the bruins
had two big victories last week from
what i heard
from my buddies back east
uh we beat the montreal canadiens in
overtime
brad marchand
uh scored
uh but shout out to the canadians they
suck this year but they still always pl
they always get up to play the bruins
man so um
you know my respect to them and then we
also beat the always [ __ ]
ridiculously difficult team the tampa
bay lightning so
that's good stuff and i heard me picked
up a defenseman i don't know his name
but all my buddies are saying it's what
we needed and i'm like is this the guy
that's gonna [ __ ] beat somebody's
roof in if they run our goaltender and
they're like well no you know he's
physical but
i don't know i still think we need one
of those guys
you know
ever since lucich and sean thornton left
i just feel like you know
you know we have not had
that person
um
i don't know
i think it's always good to have just
that one person to keep you honest oh
speaking of which i did watch a little
bit of a hockey game the other night
was it last night i watched uh
the capitals
first the hurricanes and i love watching
the capitals because they have a great
announcer and then also like total
[ __ ] like homer announcers which is
always great to listen to a homer
announcer
um
when uh when you have a guy like wilson
on your team
it's the funniest [ __ ] ever because that
hit last night against the carolina
hurricanes that was a totally clean hit
so they always go let's clean it you
know shoulder went right into his chest
he's not targeting the head or whatever
but then like whenever he like [ __ ]
takes three strides and board somebody
and tries to end their career
they'll be like they always just like
you know it was a marginal hit you know
as he started you know it's just
just like a bad luck thing where you
know if you see when he starts to skate
at him his body is turned sideways and
at the last second he turns his back you
know it's just one of those bang bang
plays you know
you see at the last second his jaw came
down to his
his uh his sternum level and uh you know
i mean wilson's skating full speed i
mean there's nothing he can do i mean he
has to protect himself
you know
not saying that bruins announcers don't
do the same thing it's just fun to hear
other people do it um
plus is it is it uh
how do you say his name i've only
listened to him a thousand [ __ ] times
is it joe
uh been in nantes been a nanty is that
how you say whatever the guy's name the
guy's incredible
uh just kind of has a great voice and
they're a fun team to watch then i
watched a little bit of the i watched
the end of the uh st louis blues game
um
congratulations to tarasenko becoming
like the
fourth i think st louis blue
to score 500 points with that team
joining or is it brett hull
uh
who the [ __ ] else played for him
al mcginnis i can't remember
i just remember brett hull i missed
brett hall how fun was that guy
i mean you know i wish more athletes
were like him and just didn't give a
[ __ ] about endorsements and just said
exactly what the hell they were thinking
i remember one time he got hurt
this was during the height of the clutch
and grab
era in hockey
and he came back and he was like you
know we need to fix this game i was out
for like 10 days
and i was watching hockey it is so
goddamn boring it's ridiculous we need
to fix the game and he got in trouble
for it
you know
i mean i guess you know he's biting the
hand that feeds but still he he was he
was a hundred percent right that was
during that time too when uh
i like mario lemieux was just like
listen i'm gonna [ __ ] retire
dude there was like guys like one had
one eighth the talent of lemieux and
they would just grab his jerseys he went
by and like basically water ski behind
him
uh trying to slow him down or whatever
um
so anyway i'm babbling here let's get on
to baseball's coming
i'm so psyched that they got through
that whatever [ __ ] whatever [ __ ]
problem there was
you know
um
it's kind of amazing to me because i
don't realize like how much money is
left in baseball
i feel like they're the number three
sport now
where you know football and basketball
are clearly getting better
or more views than they are and these
those ballparks are looking pretty empty
so
as baseball fans we need to get out
there to show it's one of the great
[ __ ] games to go to i you know the
only thing missing
and i think this is ridiculous
you can't smoke a cigar in a section you
can't stick us in the upper deck
dude if i could smoke a cigar at a ball
game while keeping score
you know when they had root beer on
[ __ ] tap you know i mean that that
would be it that would be [ __ ]
it for me
i'd have season tickets to the goddamn
dodgers if i could do that
no you can't smoke you can't smoke you
could [ __ ] gamble
you know they basically turned all these
[ __ ] sports arenas into the goddamn
dog track right now that's fine that's
fine people coming down there and
[ __ ] blowing their kids college
education fund that's totally fine but
oh god forbid you light up a [ __ ]
chesterfield do people even smoke those
anymore um
all right let's get on we'll read some
of these um
we'll read some of these these notes i
am so [ __ ] excited that that scene
went the way it went yesterday
oh billy don't [ __ ] this up edit it
together correctly all right we got two
reads here um
what do we got here two reads uh
what did what do um oh this is simply
safe everybody what do u.s news pc
magazine and popular science have in
common well they all ranked simply safe
home security as the best home security
of 2021 in fact u.s news just named
simply safe the best home security of
2022
as well
simply safe
protects your whole home around the
clock every door window and room it's
backed by the best 24 7 professional
monitoring in the business ready to
dispatch police firefighters emts to
your home with a comprehensive set of
sensors and cameras including the all
new wireless outdoor security camera you
always know what's going on inside of
your home
simply safe is less than a dollar a day
and you can set it up around 30 minutes
and it's always simple to use uh there's
never a long-term contract you can even
try
it for 60 days risk-free to see if you
like it if you don't send it back free
of charge simply save protects over a
million
over a million homes in the united
states alone you can customize the
perfect system for your home in just a
few minutes at simply safe.com
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com slash birth
s-n-s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com slash burr
oh and look who it is everybody oh it's
old zip
recruiter uh according to the latest
research this is the latest information
we have on this topic 90 of employers
plan to make enhancing the employee
experience a top priority in 2022
um after all a happy workplace is key to
attracting and keeping great employees
and if you need to add more employees to
your team their zip
their matching technology helps you find
the right people for your roles fast and
right now you can try ziprecruiter for
free at ziprecruiter.com
uses its powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates with your job
then it proactively presents these
candidates to you you can easily reviews
these recommended candidates and and
only invite your top choices to apply
nothing but blue chips for your job
which encourages them to apply faster
you know what bill belichick would do he
wouldn't take any of the top choices
he'd go with his second round draft
choice that's how he does it
i want someone who really wants this job
who feels left out zip recruiters
technology is so effective that four to
five employers who post on zip
get a quality candidate within the first
day find the right employees for your
workplace at ziprecruiter try it for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
that ziprecruiter
z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u-i-t-e-r-dot-com
b-u-r-r
the smartest way to hire all right great
emails thanks bill just wanted to say a
big thank you for bill still doing the
podcast despite his busy filming special
schedule i really appreciate it wishing
the best on his project well thank you
says thanks bill from the uk look at
that getting love from england
um
here's one build your billboard museum
uh dear bill in your podcast you talk
about the souvenir t-shirts that you
cannot throw away for sentimental
reasons i totally understand stan
totally understands
uh objects like photos help us to
remember the nice and important things
in life they trigger a memory
or maybe uh you tell a lovely story
about that particular event that you
suddenly remember again here's my
[ __ ] thing is i'm taking all pictures
of my kids
on my cell phones but then like a couple
years later they look like all pixelated
so
you know one of the actors
on the film had one of those instant
cameras whatever you call them this not
disposable the uh
the ones we take the picture in the
little square comes out the bottom
and she was just like yeah i use it for
like photo albums and stuff like that i
think i'm going to get one of those
um anyway you can tell such as you can
tell such a story to your kids
i guess with all of that stuff later of
course uh you are a good dad so your
children would like to know more about
their dad once they're adults i'm sure
of that
i know i would love it
uh love that if i were your daughter
uh and maybe some documentary filmer
will wish to talk to them long after
you're gone this person is wrapping up
my life come on man i like to think i
got a couple two three
left in me here
and then they'll uh
have some great stories to tell and some
wonderful objects to show so please
don't throw away your t-shirts and don't
throw away your cds either
uh too late for that uh don't you want
to tell them about your favorite music i
brought them down to some hipster store
gave them to cassette tapes and all that
[ __ ] a long time ago
and please keep the dvds and the vhs
tapes those i do have
just build a mini billboard museum in
your own house or your garage who the
[ __ ] wants to see my dvds and vhs tapes
a small hidden corner you don't want to
look too much love of a narcissistic
star a cupboard with boxes and
containers full of trigger objects to
evoke memories and good stories uh for
later for your kids for us fans for the
eventual documentary maker don't think
only about yourself think about us the
other people here just kidding i hope
this makes sense thanks for sharing so
much
of your life with us enjoy your weeks
off air quote and go [ __ ] yourself
regards from the netherlands look at all
this look at all this uh love i'm
getting from uh from europe
you know there's an outside chance i
might be going to a wedding
over in europe
and my wife's gonna kill me i'm already
thinking about doing a couple of shows
over there
i'll be like what it pays for the trip
you know
what do you want from me yeah the hatch
just blew
um look there was a whole box of those
things i only took a couple of them
i was going to bring them back what'd
you get lost
collector items
or collect doors items
is it collector
want to be collectors apostrophe items
athlete
um dear billy good stuff
acetate i've been collecting comic books
and unopened trading card boxes for 25
years since i was 10.
i like boxes of cards with plastic still
on them despite
what the cards are for i.e i don't like
pokemon but i have a few boxes based on
their value see this is why i stopped
collecting cards because it became like
adults doing [ __ ] like that
i mean
i just wish they would go back to the
regular football cards a two-dimensional
[ __ ] picture with all the stats on
the back and then some fun fact
you know i still remember louis culture
had a size 16 quadruple e sneaker or
cleat i still remember that
from the back of his his card and they'd
have what what
uh they'd have a college pennant and in
there they'd say what college the person
went to they'd have their height they'd
have their weight they'd have all their
stats
it was everything you needed it was
amazing
um
anyways it says i was told for years
that they would be worth nothing and
that my comics would be devalued by the
over printing of variants
god that is a popular word
variant
the delta variant of captain america
imagine 15 different cards for the same
player in the same series uh anyways and
loss of interest in the markets
the truth is that there have been ups
and downs but overall everything is up
significantly when kids would rush to
open 50 packs to find a certain card i
would just buy a box and hold on to it
lots of times boxes are guaranteed to
have a certain card for example i have
boxes that surely have expensive rookie
cards but i have never opened the box
that's like these [ __ ] jerk-offs who
buy a ferrari
you know
or that [ __ ] what's that ford car
the mid-engine one that won le mans
whatever the [ __ ] that thing is
they'll buy the thing
and then like
they'll sell it at mecum auction 15
years later and it's got like [ __ ]
you know 600 original miles it's like
you're a jerk off
that thing should have [ __ ] 300 000
miles on it you bought it as an
investment you don't buy a ferrari is an
investment you drive you buy it to drive
the [ __ ] thing
they have like 1600 miles on them like
that better all be at the track
anyway um
so this person didn't open he said i was
wondering if you get regret uh getting
rid of anything that you're in you're
getting rid of anything phase i don't
and i'll be honest with you i can't even
remember what i got rid of i mean i get
rid of my football cards because they
mean so much to me
um
but you know uh
you know other things just knickknacks
and [ __ ] like that i i don't anyways he
said uh he or she said i should mention
that i sold five boxes of unopened cards
in 2020 and i made over 250 000 from
them
it barely affected my collection and i
was able to buy a house well there you
go man
i mean you're doing it right i mean if
that's good for you
good for you are there even jobs anymore
like i don't even know what people do
there's
it's it's kind of like a [ __ ]
i guess we don't make anything in this
country anymore thank god for [ __ ]
people growing weed
we still grow food we grow weed
you know
and you got uh the shinola company
that makes watches bicycles
and all types of [ __ ] like that
out of detroit there's a few out there
hey
if you're an american company and you
make some [ __ ]
uh
right into the podcast i'll give you a
shout out here help your business we got
to get things going here again
um all right badass thing i shouldn't
own but i do i really like this topic
this is that thing you know
where you know you make a little bit of
money
and there's something you always wanted
and you go out and get it and then you
get it
and as much as you're excited that you
have it there's a part of you that says
in the back your head you know this this
isn't really made for me
this is made you know
you know for some badass guy that got
into a bunch of bar fights
you know and bang the hottest chicks in
town you know what i mean that type of
[ __ ] it's like you know i have a gibson
les paul
guitar and i absolutely [ __ ] love it
but there is this part of me whenever i
put it on and i see myself in the mirror
with it i'm just like you know
i i don't
you know you think you're going to look
like slash or jimmy page and you don't
you just look like a dad
you know who went to some [ __ ] i
don't know a guitar center anyway badass
thing i shouldn't own but i do
dear baron von burgundy balls i like
that you gave me a little nobility there
about six months ago my brother and i
inherited an old kawasaki motorcycle
from our uncle that's [ __ ] awesome
that's that's something that i owned
that i knew i owned a triumph bonneville
for about six weeks and i was just like
yeah this isn't me
although i think a ducati might be me
you know
um this thing is beautiful it's been
living under a tarp in this
in his garage literally since the 1970s
it looks like it just rolled out of the
showroom
um
i'll tell you right now if you want to
sell it i know a dean del rey will buy
that in a second
uh the two of us decided that we'd learn
to ride and would share custody of the
bike this is such a great story so far
my brother has fulfilled his side of the
bargain but being the [ __ ] that i am
i've been dragging my heels on actually
taking the plunge and learning to ride
the bike to be honest the prospect of
having an accident scares the living
[ __ ] out of me then you shouldn't ride
because that's what i that was what i
was like
and i can't decide if it's worth the
risk if i ever ended up in a wheelchair
or worse i'd honestly rather be dead
yeah man
i mean with the amount that people are
texting out there it's like everybody
out there has a couple two three drinks
in them
and uh yeah i just don't feel like
losing a leg and [ __ ] you know
not only could i not [ __ ] i'd lose a
leg i couldn't play drums anymore you
know
[ __ ] that anyway it's still not the well
or at least i'd have to adjust how i
play it uh anyway it's not the
motorcycle that i'm writing to you about
it's a badass leather biker jacket that
i bought when i was still entertaining
the idea of riding the bike i bought the
jacket second hand and it's literally
the toughest piece of clothing i've ever
seen it's made in melbourne australia
where i live in the 1960s and at some
point thereafter had an eagle painted on
the back
think more hell's angels than ed hardy
it's also got those metal studs on the
shoulders oh there's the picture
oh yeah yeah that's a badass jacket um
when i wear this thing i feel like the
toughest man alive which i'm clearly not
given that i'm too scared to actually
ride a motorcycle but i also wondered
where the jacket came from and worried
that i'm unwittingly unwittingly
representing a biker gang i keep waiting
for an irate bikey in a matching jacket
to approach me and ask where the [ __ ]
did you get that
um anyway i have no intention of getting
rid of the jacket even though i am a
[ __ ] and a total poser i've attached a
photo for your enjoyment keep up the
good work and go [ __ ] yourself you
bald-headed [ __ ] um first of all
i don't think you are a [ __ ]
um
you know it takes a strong man to admit
that they're too afraid to do something
and not the amount of guys that were
like i don't want to look like a [ __ ]
and then died you don't want to be that
guy
you know and i'll tell you something
that's one of the great things about
getting older is you don't give a [ __ ]
people ask you something and you feel
fear and you just you jus you
you know you validate it you're like i'm
not doing that [ __ ]
and then you know what happens nine
times out of ten the other guys just
laugh
i bet that would still happen when you
learn what are you chicken uh no i'm
smart
go ahead i want to see you do it go get
yourself all [ __ ] up
i'll be over here with my intact
skeletal system
uh underrated
advice going into ford slash advice
going into 40. all right underrated your
30s
bill i am the happiest i've ever been
and i think it's because i'm in my 30s
look at that people everybody in your
20s who don't want to be in your 30s
here's something positive uh i don't
care what people say uh i'm a hundred
percent into my own [ __ ] these days i
wish i focused more in my twenties and
wasn't such a dummy no no you got that's
what your 20s are all about your 20s are
all about making mistakes
your 30s you look back you figure it out
and guess what your 40s are even better
you just keep fine-tuning it
you know until you're like 70.
and then that's why everybody loves a
[ __ ] cool old man because if you did
the work throughout your life and you
keep trying to be a better version of
yourself
oh wait didn't somebody say that the
other night at an award show i wasn't
even that much of a dummy
and i still say that
i wasted a few years at a job that i
knew i didn't care about well who
doesn't do that
i had a girlfriend and we loved each
other but it doesn't matter because when
you're going in one direction trying to
pursue a dream and she
and she's going in the other it
eventually snaps yeah and there's
nothing wrong with that
because
if you didn't go after the dream
there's a very high percentage that you
would eventually
resent her
you know
and then you take it out on her and then
it dies or
you don't resent her you put it on
yourself where it belongs and then
you're just depressed and then she
leaves you because you're just a [ __ ]
you know
wet blanket to hang out with i don't
know you got to go after the dream
um anyway i think if i can hold on to
this through my 40s 50s and so on then
i'll be really happy yeah absolutely
absolutely
you do that and then
you're not afraid of dying i don't mean
you have like a death wish but you
really just
look at death that it's going to be this
peaceful thing and it's going to be this
great release and be thankful
that you were alive and got to live
and did the things that you wanted to do
successes and failures like [ __ ] all
this religious [ __ ] that makes you
afraid of dying and
you know putting all this [ __ ] crap
on you because it's uh it's not right
it's a terrible thing to do to people
and it comes from other human beings and
it comes from human beings from a long
time ago
so it's uh you know
i mean a long time ago you know you had
some sort of [ __ ]
sickness and they'd stick a bunch of
leeches on you thinking they would suck
it out of you i mean those are the same
people that were have been telling you
what's gonna happen after you're dead
[ __ ] all of that i think death is uh an
amazing amazing experience and should be
enjoyed
you know unless somebody else is [ __ ]
killing you then yeah obviously no
uh but you know if you're lucky enough
to live into your [ __ ] old age
i think that you handle it with grace
that's that's
i mean
the very least i mean that's the [ __ ]
attitude to go into it with because it's
gonna happen
right
um
i don't know that'd be a funny [ __ ]
masterclass
how to die
anyway as a guy who had uh an amazing
run in his 30s
how did you keep it going oh me i had an
amazing runnings my 30s dude my 30s were
tough oh those are rough ones
um
but i think i was a sort of unique
case of uh my case was special um i was
really really really shut down
in my 20s and into my my
30s so my 30s is when i became my
angriest
because what i wanted what i really
wanted was to be married and have a big
family that's what i always wanted
and i didn't know how to do it so i
thought going on a stage and acting like
an idiot and getting people to like me
that the girl of my dreams was just
automatically going to walk up to me
like wow i saw your show you're really
funny do you want to get married and i'd
be like okay
like that's
literally
i mean that's a simplistic version of
how it was going to be in my life but
what i was really doing was i was
you know not working on how
anti-social and how much of a loner and
what a [ __ ] walled off protected
place
i put myself in
so um
you know
how did i keep how did i get out of that
it's more the question is i don't know i
just started going to therapy and i
started working on myself and i also
kind of like when i looked at [ __ ] that
i wasn't happy with my life rather than
blame other people i was trying to see
how i was contributing to it
and then i don't know once i started
thinking positive i really think that i
started to go back to who i was before
all the [ __ ] that happened to me
happened to me
and i don't know it's like you see that
light and then you're like oh [ __ ] and
you just start running towards it
and now like i don't know
after being super negative and depressed
and all that now i'm on this other place
where it's just like
if i feel that [ __ ]
i'm hyper sensitive to it and i i just
know what i'll go play drums
you know uh
you know go to the gym you know go play
with my kids
you know
take the family out to a restaurant go
do some fun [ __ ] that'll you know i can
look forward to and i immediately can
get myself out of it and i also got rid
of a lot of [ __ ]
you know
other damaged people who weren't working
on themselves that's a big thing if
you're a damaged person i mean i'll
forgive you for that [ __ ] but if you're
not working on yourself and you're
[ __ ] taking your childhood on me i'm
out
so
you know that's another good thing when
you get older you're able to fast
forward through relationships
because you know you met that type of a
person before and you're just kind of
like oh i know what this is and i know
how this ride goes and guess what i'm
getting off before the ride even [ __ ]
starts that's the best
that's the best all right everybody that
is the podcast thank you so much
for your patience um thank you to
everybody that's buying tickets
for birmingham alabama and macon georgia
those are two days after i rap
on this movie i cannot
[ __ ] wait to get all of this these
jokes that i got building up in me
um
out there in the bible belt all right
you guys know i love alabama you know
i'm going to saw's barbecue
um i've haven't been to macon georgia i
don't know if i've ever been there i
don't think i've ever been there but i
believe the theater that i'm playing in
is an incredibly historic theater i
believe it's the same one they actually
had martin luther king uh
funeral there so this is an epic place
humbling place to be able to perform at
and that's it that's the podcast go
bruins and one more time people
you know
one more time
congratulations to quest love winning
oscar and everybody who won an oscar
it's an incredible
achievement i hope at some point you go
back and you watch
and remember who won this year all right
okay
we uh we shall see you guys uh go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll talk to you i'll
check in on you on thursday
you